thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon
good morning dear colleagues we have
with us
today the president of Portugal Marcelo
Roberto de Souza
president
thank you for being a lot to address
this house in 2016.
you anticipated many of our common
challenges and spoke of issues that
continue to be relevant today
in the face of adversity you called for
Unity and solidarity because you
understood
already then that we had more to gain by
working together
that is how we dealt with the pandemic
that is how we stood up to the Russian
aggression in Ukraine president I would
like to commend you on your efforts in
protecting our European values and in
fighting social exclusion
the social and economic impact of the
war in Ukraine the energy prices and an
increased inflation rate across our
Union are once again testing our unity
and commitment towards those values
the call for more unity and solidarity
is perhaps today more pressing than ever
before this is the moment to stand
together this is Europe's moment to stay
United new political and security
challenges pose a greater more complex
threat to our democracies the rise of
populism and neuroskepticism fueled by
information Warfare and disinformation
campaigns seek to erode trust in
Democratic institutions by hampering
citizens from making informed decisions
how we responded to this and how we will
continue to respond to those looking to
undermine our democracy will be the
litmus test of our values here I am
convinced that Portugal will continue to
play its parts surveys after surveys
show that the Portuguese population is
exceedingly
euro-optimistic especially about the
future of the European Union this is
encouraging and yet we must keep doing
more more to bring the message of Europe
closer to our people more to show that
the values that bind us as Europeans is
still so much greater than what can ever
seek to divide us and more to assure our
citizens that their vote at the European
elections next year does in fact matter
estimado president
[Applause]
thank you
this is
just a few words
and Europe has no time to lose first of
all to congratulate you madam president
and you're young
determined and Visionary mandate
confirming that in the current Europe
there is room for everyone without
inevitable differences at geography
history demography the or the cultural
social economic or political diversity
um distance
and it will always be
albeit in crisis
[Music]
institutions
we believe in European security
20th century
we believed in the
and at the advantage of Human Rights
of globalization
the Union
excellent
the times
and transatlantic cooperation and a
future oriented way
emergency
[Applause]
a cycle under emergency under a pandemic
yes
just one year from the European
elections
yes
but much harder to answer
both economic and social either boys
effective Global power yes or no
which will take longer
playing the weakest possible
foreign
no ambient
[Music]
millions of Europeans
speed up no meaning
and also the political impact of
inflation
the combined effects of pandemicism and
closer to you
foreign
[Music]
does the union wish to be alert
proactive
the European Union
must not forget
that study Physics
it is very difficult
for people to understand that this is a
European War yes
the agreements and Partnerships
and in certain cases
suggestions
[Applause]
to begin to tackle these challenges
digital Technologies
Tuesday
a European Union of the service of Youth
solidarity between the generations
to renew itself slow to uh
response
and the only possible response
should accelerate Generations
we cannot forget
sacrifices
in times of war and pandemic
support and focus on youths
we cannot alienate young people
we must
participation
rejuvenate political systems
social systems
and if this happens
simply because we failed to do what we
must
and failed to do it
before it was too late
um
bearing in mind that even before 2029
numerous
and in some cases without the
possibility
foreign
[Music]
but there is another way
with vague ideas
meaningless institutional discussions
that is
our future with a medium to long-term
vision
foreign
and to look to the medium and long-term
future
people of Portugal believe in Europe yes
and
a leadership role that is anticipating
the future and doesn't it
that doesn't belong to heads of state
government
belongs to to the men and women of yours
this is the Europe that we want to say
yes
the millions of Europeans deserves
and Europe as always will prevail
[Applause]
thank you very very much president thank
you the session will now close and we
will resume with the votes thank you
very much president for that amazing
speech